[Laughter]
it's amazing
like as you get older the things that
you realize that really [__] with you
like people always say oh my god if you
see somebody getting beat up as a kid
you're going to grow up and be a rapist
no you're not
no you know i've seen a thousand people
get beat up when i was a kid i seen
people get shot and i'm [__] fine you
know what i'm saying
i like torching jehovah whatever the
[__] i like my own little things but i'm
fine you know
the thing that [__] me up the most i
sit here now and look at is when
i go out with guys and when guys get
together they talk about women they talk
about this
and also as the later that i guess they
talk about hookers and strip clubs and
all that craziness which i'm a dirty
filthy [__] animal i like [__] like
the next i'm not gonna sit here
i'm not a christian oh my god he's
talking dirty but you eat ass you know
what i'm saying
i never understood the correlation so we
all eat ass we've all been down there
we all know the [__] rules you know
but one thing i can't deal with is
hookers
like prostitution i'm no [__] i'm no
good looking guy if you look at me like
joey's been with some hookers let me
tell you something
one [__] time and that's all i needed
was one time and it was the most
uncomfortable
[__] feeling for me and then in
michigan in 95
i have bad shoulders and i seen those
signs massage
and i walked in i go how much for
massaging they did the [__]
switcheroo on me they threw
lucy lou at me you know what i'm saying
first and then when i walked in they too
looked like the d
team at me some chick with a hump and
she's like for four dollars i'll give
you a hand job and i'm like [__] you
[__] and i left there
and i kept thinking forty dollars for a
[__] hand job how impersonal you know
what i'm saying
you could do that you see what i'm
saying like just and it's but people are
into that i'm not here to judge nobody
whatever some people like a finger up
there you know whatever
whatever you like but it's funny like
the thing like still to today like
sometimes in the afternoons i'm trying
to write jokes
and i'm on youtube you know watching my
[__] movie videos
i like music from youtube and sometimes
like i'll hit you and the p
will come up and i hit you porn and i'm
i'm [__] you know what i'm saying
listen i'm like the next guy i love a
naked woman you know what i'm saying but
then you watch i feel like a minute i
get turned off
the number one reason women on youtube
like to do all that dirty [__] with
dirty feet
listen if you're going to suck a dick do
me a favor wash your feet that's all you
know what i'm saying
at first it turns you on you're like
that chick walked a mile to suck a dick
that you know
but then you're like all right after you
walk the mile wash your feet put some
cream on them i want them soft
i would never eat your [__] with dirty
feet you know what i'm saying i'm a
catholic i wash my [__] feet
i wash my i wash my dick if i'm gonna
eat your [__] because that's the kind
of guy i am
that's how my mother raised the soldier
you know what i'm saying wash yourself
you want the woman to look at you nuts
you got to wash them put some soap on
them pick them up
you know what i'm saying buff them shave
them you got you know i'm saying that's
one thing
what was i talking about bro
[Music]
uh hookers i don't like [__] you know
it's not that i don't like them it's not
like i go out and shoot hookers
i just when somebody says you know for
five hundred dollars we could
you know what i'll pass i'll go whack
off and i go to the room
i'll think about [__] huh for free
you know what i'm saying
but i won't get and the reason why is
because when i was like [__] 16
my cuban buddy pedro obregon his family
had a candy
company in uh the bronx and he used to
take home the
the candy truck at night it was great
you smoked pot with them and eat [__]
m
m's and lollipops and and all those
spanish candies their parents had all
those [__]
containers with the coquito and all that
[__] in it right so
we go out with them at night because you
have to pay for munchies you just drove
around [__] new york with them
but one night they're like [__] it we're
gonna go to this hooker house and they
would always talk about
they would always talk about how they
would go into these houses in brooklyn
and these women would take your dick out
and wash it for you and
and put you on this bed and [__]
these guys were young they had been
doing it for three or four years
and i'm like i was scared like that that
was just too real for me but this night
they're like listen we're going to the
club you're coming and i was
this is why you always [__] go out in
your own car
that's what this goes back to never go
out in somebody else's car [__] that
[__] i'll take my car i'll meet you
there you know what i'm saying
so if they they can't tie you into [__]
that's how i learned this [__] lesson
this all goes back to that
take your own [__] car and mind your
business
no i'm with eight guys like nobody's
gonna get laid when they
did nobody's gonna get [__] nobody it's
eight [__] idiots
so right away at two like it looks like
we're not gonna get no [__] i wasn't
looking
i'm with eight guys i know we're not in
[__] danger because once you see one
eight of them [__] attacker they're
like let's go to the 1040 club the 1040
club was a hooker club
like in the west side of new york like
48th street it was 9.99
plus tax 10 40.
and you went you paid 11 they gave you
60 cents back
and a [__] coupon like a raffle
coupon
and you walked into a room like this
with like 300 guys
that have all gotten laid and they're
all pimps and you know
they all have orgies and they all have
cologne on with the tick chains and
you know and they had a bar where you
could buy drinks and every 20 minutes
they pulled like a garage door open
like three little midgets came out and
pulled the garage door open
and they'd push out like 100 girls into
the audience
it was [__] traumatizing and they
were talking all different languages are
you that may you know
like help me i don't want to go i don't
want to go like
i had to grow an apocalypse now the kid
that did i don't want to go i don't want
to go
and then just be pushing them out
hitting them with sticks and [__] get
out of here
and there's 300 guys so you got to get
one of the chicks there's 100 chicks
so you got to [__] tackle them you
know what i'm saying and half the time
you got to get into a fish fight i seen
the first [__] and you got
like you gotta grab them and after you
grab them they're not yours you gotta
carry them back to the ticket guy give
him their ticket
she gotta like kick him in the ankles
and drag him a little bit you know what
i'm saying
and they're crying no are you the man
you're like [__] i paid ten dollars at
40 cents
there's noah you that may hear you know
what i'm saying
this was that's the first time i ever
seen human trafficking
because i understand spanish but they
were talking all different [__]
languages there
and all of them sound like are you lame
which means help me in spanish right
so my friend's like come on coco get in
here grab one of these [__]
i'm like what the [__] i was overwhelmed
people are fighting it was like a
[__] bar scene
it was like a scene from the chinese
connection people were sidekicking
themselves
so finally my buddy grabs this chick and
throws it like you coco here
i got one for you so i [__] grab her
i kick her in the ankle you know what
i'm saying
because you got a dragon my yes
this is such a bad [__] story but
it's either you or the priest you know
what i'm saying
so so
[Applause]
and i ate a piece of red velvet cake i'm
a little high right now that's
if i'm forgetting my material work with
me people you know where i'm coming from
so i carry into the back you gotta give
the guy the lottery ticket and then he's
like okay you're free to go and
and i carry into the back and the back
isn't no spacious bedroom with a view of
manhattan
you know john lennon music on the piping
on the [__] airwaves [__] no
it was like a japanese radio on ding
ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding
i remember that song to the death you
understand me
as i'm getting led into purgatory i'll
never forget that song like
what is your song yeah
[Music]
and there was like one chinese girl in
the back so they were like wasting
[__] good music
for people it was red right you know
what i'm saying they read from right to
left
so we go on the back and it's [__] up
it's [__] up it's like little office
cubicles but real small like
and it was like a ping pong pool
mattress you know what those are where
your mom opens up and it's got wheels
like when your uncle comes over and
it's like it was one of those things
that had been busted up like a million
people had been [__] on it the wheels
were [__] up
it was held up by hangers and tv wires
and [__]
and it had like a half a mattress cut in
half and you had a [__] on the
on the coils half the time and [__] so
she's like take your dick out
you know i had never done that before
for a girl you know you take it out
yourself in a rush and [__] in the dark
and
you know but this was real this was a
little [__] real now
you know when you're 16 you have to
[__] rush your grandma's coming your
mom's coming at 3 30.
you're gonna come in a minute anyway but
you know
i had never taken off all your clothes
and enjoyed it like a savage you know
what i'm saying so
she is a [__] nightmare she's got the
stockings with the holes in it
but then somebody ripped some of the
[__] holes so i
like the whole time i'm like what did i
get myself into now and i'm like mommy
under my leg and i'm saying
mommy mommy are you that man
mommy please help me i don't need this
[__] and she's taking off her planty
hose and what it was with something else
now she had scars and [__]
and the titties were smaller she had
padding in there i got tricked that into
that too
you know what i'm saying because you
fall for the tricks i got the padding i
know she now she got funnel titties
and then she turns around and she takes
a bucket out to wash my dick that's the
highlight like that's what the guys
they wash your dick but this bucket had
been reused water
it was like it was like rocky spit
bucket at rocky too you know what i'm
saying
i had the foam up on the top and shins
and she's over there wetting my helmet
with a sponge that's half there like
it's got like cooking utensil grease on
it and [__]
and i'm dying inside like i am done like
this is an experience with a hooker this
is [__] hard
this is hot i'm a young man this is just
[__] taking me for a ride you know
at the time you had seen [__] like in
playboy her [__] was a complete
different [__] situation it had hair
up here it was missing patches
you know what i'm saying she was rubbing
proficia on the one half
i mean it was just a [__] when she
opened it up i
wanted to cry i didn't know what and
then she was like she doubled as a
magician because i had never seen that
trick
she went like this she was like you know
something like a condom came out of a
[__] mouth
i had never seen i'm like wow
and she's like give me that little dick
and she put it on with her mouth which
was [__] amazing
how'd you do that and then she's like
what do you want
50 50 and around the world 50 50 sounded
all right around the world like i didn't
think i was
i don't have a passport you know what
i'm saying man
i can't even go to jamaica and [__] you
know
and she's like well lay down and she got
on top and she's like
like it wasn't an he said she was
[__] me sideways like
because the springs were all [__] up
and she was real she was taking it to
court and i had never been rocked like
that like and i could hear the condom
hitting her [__] and like
and i was getting [__] anxiety and i
was yelling for my mother
mommy mama mama this is all under my
breath you know what i'm saying i'm
trying to be a pimp you know what i'm
saying
i'm like my mom i'm trying to send like
subliminal messages to my mother my mom
my mom and i feel like [__] crying
like guys you ever want to [__] cry
like
this is the lowest point of my life i
thought i was going to have sex and i
was going to hear flowers and i was
going to hit on john music
and i'm [__] on a half a mattress
with some chick from another country
that
doesn't even have a [__] shots in
their arms you know you always check
to see if they got the the [__]
vampire bite on their arm
i'm thinking of all this [__] i'm like
this is not what my life is supposed to
[__] be
you know like when did he get to this
and all of a sudden she stops
and she goes for an extra ten dollars
i'll let you eat my [__]
and remember when nogueira fought tim
sylvia
and he picked that [__] up like
that swooped him around
i didn't do that i picked her up and
just drew out of the [__] cubicle
and i ran the [__] out of there you
understand me and i've never been with a
hooker since
nor have any [__] plans to be with a
hooker you understand me
and i'm the horniest guy in the world if
you like hookers [__] kill them
i love it i love when i hear somebody
lighting a hooker on fire or something
i love all that [__] that's
entertainment if i'm gonna pay you i'm
gonna get a [__] laugh out of it you
know what i'm saying
thank you very much coming out tonight
to the improv coming out from my
recording
i love you guys stay black baby